the easiest way to find the square root
of any number is to use a calculator but
if you are asked to find the square root
of a number without using a calculator
there are two ways in which we can do it
the first method is phenomenally simple
it's called the prime factorization
method we will look at the second method
in the coming videos if you have watched
the previous video you should be
familiar with what square roots are so
we can look at square roots of slightly
larger numbers in this video so we want
to find the square root of 225
our aim is very simple we have to reduce
this number to its prime factors that's
all how do we do it before we go ahead
let us revise what prime numbers are a
prime number is a number which is
divisible only by itself and one say 5 5
is divisible by one and it's divisible
by 5 there is no other number which can
divide 5 1 and itself
hence it's a prime number let's consider
8 8 is divisible by 1 2 4 and 8
apart from 1 and itself it's also
divisible by 2 and 4 hence it's not a
prime number so let us start reducing
the number 225 into prime factors prime
factors are the factors of this number
which are prime we can write 225 as 5
multiplied by 45 5 is prime but 45 isn't
so let's reduce 45 further and write 225
as 5 times 5 times 9 we wrote 45 as 5
times 9 5 is a prime factor but 9 isn't
9 can be written as 3 times 3 hence 225
can be written as 5 times 5 times 3
times 3 in this way we reduce 225 into
its prime factors this was simple but is
it the quickest way
no let's look at a quicker way we write
225 like this and draw two lines here
like this 225 is divisible by five so we
write a 5 here we just write the prime
factors in this column 5 multiplied by
45
gives us 225 45 is not prime hence we
continue with this process 45 is also
divisible by 5
hence we write a 5 here and 5 multiplied
by 9 gives us 45 9 is not prime and we
can say that 3 x 3 equals 9 that's where
we stop when we get a prime factor here
so if we look carefully we have got all
the prime factors 5 times 5 times 3
times 3 why do I say this method is
faster look at the first 5 in this
method we continue to write it every
step then we repeat the 5 times 5 we got
in this step in the third step many of
the numbers are repeated in every step
and hence there is a bit of a redundancy
if you really want to know how tedious
this method can get try reducing 216
into its prime factors by now we should
be fairly comfortable with prime
factorization but now we're getting to
the most important point how will this
help us find the square root of 225 you
will not believe how simple it is we
write this as square root of 5 times 5
times 3 times 3 we have to make groups
of 2 same numbers this can be our first
group 5 and 5 we can make another group
3 and 3 we basically formed pairs of
same numbers so we have two pairs of
same numbers here 5 & 5 & 3 & 3 once we
form pairs to find the square root all
we have to do is pick one number from
each pair and multiply them so from the
first pair we pick 5 and from the second
pair we
pick three and we multiply five and
three which gives us 15 at first this
seems long but with practice it gets
very simple hence we can say that the
square root of 225 is 15 all we did is
broke down the number to its prime
factors mate pairs chose one number from
each pair and multiplied them in the
next part of this video we will see how
we can find the square root of 11,000 25
using this method
you